grillages fermé locaux vides depuis près
de neuf mois l'ancienne université
thales devrait rouvrir ses portes d'ici
quelques semaines pour se transformer en
centre de formation pour réfugiés avec
le soutien de la préfecture
d'ile-de-france et emmaüs solidarité 300
personnes suivront des cours sur place
durant six mois
objectif leur enseigner le français et
faciliter leur intégration
professionnelle
un projet étalé en tout sur 9 ans auquel
s'est ralliée la mairie après avoir
préempté le terrain il y à plus d'un an
on y adhère je dirais par par par
nécessité par obligation mais on y
adhère aussi parce que c'est un projet
qui nous semble avoir du sens nous
semblera du sens que de former que de
près former des personnes réfugiées en
france qui ont de petits bénéficient du
droit d'asile de façon à leur permettre
de s'intégrer dans les meilleures
conditions dans la société française
dévoilée dont le détail aux habitants
début avril lors d'une réunion publique
le projet suscite depuis des réactions
entre inquiétude et étonnement pour
certains il est aussi critiquée par le
front national qui réclame la tenue d'un
référendum local sur le sujet la
proportion de ce centre est assez
inédite
ça va évidemment modifier le visage de
la ville je pense que les premiers
concernés sont les personnes à la ville
mais exigent aussi les élus et les
personnes qui habitent versailles grand
parc parce que les infrastructures vont
être aussi sollicité sur l'ensemble de
versailles grand parc face aux demandes
d'un scrutin local la mairie assure que
le conseil municipal est légitime en la
matière et qu'un ancien référendum
n'avait réuni que 2 100 votants sur cinq
mille électeurs potentiels
le maire est également en discussions
avec les différentes parties pour
faciliter le suivi et l'évaluation du
projet les premiers réfugiés devrait
loger et suivre des cours dans la
verdure jova sienne d'ici mi juin une
visite des lieux est prévue au préalable
pour les habitants intéressés